When Baron Pierre de Coubertin founded the
International Olympic Committee (IOC) in 1894,
he declared that one of the missions of the
modern Olympiad would be “to reunite in
the bonds of legitimate wedlock a long-divorced
couple — Muscle and Mind.”
To the Baron, Olympic competition wasn’t
just going to be about physical athletics,
but sports of the mind as well – and there
are fewer greater “sports of the mind”
than the arts.
From 1912 to 1948, in seven Olympiads, over
151 Olympic medals were awarded in artistic
competitions.
Growing up in the French autocracy, Coubertin
valued a classical education.
He loved sports, especially rugby, but there
is little evidence he was particularly athletic
himself.
As his career as an educator gained steam,
he pressed for more physical education in
schools.
He believed sports to be democratic, blurring
class lines, but he also thought of physical
education as a way to prepare the youth for
the rigors of war.
After all, when he was but a boy, he saw his
beloved country humiliated in the Franco-Prussian
War (or “War of 1870”).
Coubertin always admired how the ancient Greeks
were able to combine classical and physical
education, the epitome of this being the ancient
Olympiad.
So, he made an announcement to a Parisian
sporting association in November 1892 that
he was going to bring back the Olympic Games
and make them an international competition.
In April 1896, the first modern, international
Olympic Games commenced in Athens, Greece.
While 43 events encompassing 9 sports took
place that first year, there were no art competitions.
That was supposed to change in 1908.
With Coubertin pushing for the inclusion of
art competitions into the Games, there was
a plan in place to make that happen.
Unfortunately, it didn’t work out due to
several factors that were out of the Baron’s
control.
Early in 1907, only 18 months before the 1908
Olympiad, the IOC (which Coubertin was the
head of) changed the location of the Games
from Rome, Italy to London.
The eruption of Mount Vesuvius in 1906 and
a struggling economy made the Games infeasible
in Rome.
The rushed preparation in London caused several
events to be cancelled, including the art
competitions.
At the Stockholm, Sweden Games in 1912, art
competitions officially became part of the
Olympiad.
This happened despite several prominent organizations,
including the Stockholm Organizing Committee,
being against attaching art competitions to
the Olympics.
They thought it was “meaningless” and
logistically challenging.
Nonetheless, the Baron had made up his mind
and he pushed it through.
Art was to become an official Olympic “sport.”
In September 1911, ten months prior to the
1912 Opening Ceremonies, a call for submissions
was published with a list of rules and regulations.
There were to be five categories of submissions:
architecture, music, painting, sculpture and
literature.
All the works submitted “must be original
and directly inspired by the idea of sport.”
Additionally, the announcement contained a
promise:
“Each of the laureates of the five contests
will receive the medals of the Vth Olympiad.
The winning works will be as much as possible
displayed, published, or executed in the course
of the Games.”
The 1912 Olympics only received 33 submissions
(nearly all from Europeans), but still gave
away five gold medals.
However, because of the small number and the
underwhelming quality of the entries, silver
and bronze were not awarded in four of the
five categories.
The gold medal winners included a building
plan for a “modern” stadium by two Swiss
architects, a sculpture of a horse pulling
a chariot by an American sculptor who had
already won two athletic gold medals for sharpshooting,
and an “Ode to Sport” penned by Germans
“George Hohrod and Martin Eschbach.”
As it turns out, Hohrod and Eschbach were
pseudonyms for the person who really wrote
the ode – the Baron himself.
Understandably fearful they wouldn’t have
enough entries, he took it upon himself to
help the cause.
Rather suspiciously, his ode won gold.
Though the 1916 Olympic Games were cancelled
due to World War I, art was again on the Olympic
program in the 1920 Berlin Olympics and the
1924 Games in Paris, where they received submission
from 193 artists.
At the 1928 Amsterdam Olympics, over 1100
works of art were submitted and put on display
at the Municipal Museum.
The Olympic art competition was now big enough
that it was attracting real talent, including
Italian sculptor Rembrandt Bugatti, American
cartoonist Percy Crosby, and Dutch painter
Isaac Israëls.
Despite this bringing legitimacy to the competition,
it brought up the question of amateurism.
Technically, all Olympic participants were
supposed to be amateurs, but many artists
used their well-regarded skills to make money,
particularly the architects and musicians
who almost universally were employed in those
professions.
How do you have a valid art competition with
highly skilled artists if those entering weren’t
allowed to make a living off their art?
Nevertheless, the art competitions were a
hit.
For instance, at the 1932 Olympics in Los
Angeles, nearly 400,000 visitors went to check
out the art entries at the Los Angeles Museum
of History.
The 1936 Olympics in Berlin are infamous for
several reasons, many of which were related
to the rise of Hitler and the Nazi party in
Germany.
The Third Reich’s Minister of Propaganda,
Joseph Goebbels, felt the need to remind the
German people that work entered into the competition
needed to have been created within the last
four years, i.e. when the Nazi party came
into power.
Not surprisingly, Germans won more than half
of the gold medals given out in artistic competitions
in 1936.
As for the Baron Pierre de Coubertin, he had
stepped down as IOC president in 1925 and
was in failing health in 1936 (he would pass
away in 1937) and didn’t even attend the
Olympics in 1936.
Despite being French, he was greatly respected
in Germany for his revival of the Olympic
Games, which very much played into the hands
of the Aryan masculinity mystique that the
Nazi party promoted.
With no Olympics in 1944 due to World War
II, the London Olympics in 1948 would be the
last time an art competition would be officially
part of the Olympic Games.
The amateur question played a major factor
in its removal after a report was presented
demonstrating that virtually all of the artists
submitting their works for their respective
art competitions were also making money on
their art.
A later report stated that it was, “illogical
that professionals should compete at such
exhibitions and be awarded Olympic medals.”
With the question of amateur and professionals
hanging over the competition, it diluted the
entry pool and by 1952, medals were no longer
awarded on submissions of art to the Olympics.
Leni Riefenstahl filmed the 1936 Olympics,
at the behest of Hitler, and turned it into
a Nazi propaganda film called “Olympia.”
While, overwhelmingly, it showed Germans looking
and performing like superior athletes, it
did capture the greatness of Jesse Owens.
In fact, the film clip the public often sees
of Owens running during the 1936 Olympics
is from this film.
There is a story that Hitler snubbed 4 time
gold medal winner Jesse Owens by leaving the
Olympic Stadium when he was supposed to be
congratulating medal winners, including Owens.
Owens denied the claim that Hitler snubbed
him during the games, “Hitler had a certain
time to come to the stadium and a certain
time to leave.
It happened he had to leave before the victory
ceremony after the 100 meters.
But before he left, I was on my way to a broadcast
and passed near his box.
He waved at me and I waved back.”
Hitler also later sent Owens an inscribed
commemorative photograph of himself.
Owens further went on to say, “Hitler didn’t
snub me – it was FDR who snubbed me.
The President didn’t even send me a telegram…
When I came back to my native country, after
all the stories about Hitler, I couldn’t
ride in the front of the bus.
I had to go to the back door.
I couldn’t live where I wanted.
I wasn’t invited to shake hands with Hitler
but I wasn’t invited to the White House
to shake hands with the President either.”
To make matters worse, when Owens arrived
at his own reception party at the Waldorf
hotel after a parade, he was not allowed to
enter via the main doors and also was not
allowed to use the normal elevators, once
inside.
Instead, he had to use a freight elevator
to get to his own party.